dans un sommet où règnent les divisions
justin trudeau a décidé de s'afficher
auprès de ses alliés traditionnels
famille pas de rencontre officielle
cependant avec d'autres dirigeants plus
controversé les sujets épineux ont été
abordés derrière les portes closes
loin des caméras j'ai pris l'occasion de
souligner directement à vladimir poutine
qu'on est extrêmement préoccupé par la
situation dans la mer d'azov le premier
ministre a appelé à la libération des
marins ukrainiens détenu par la russie
dans la foulée d'une escalade des
tensions au large de la crimée en marge
du souper des lieder le premier ministre
dit s'être adressé aux sulfureux mohamed
ben salman justin trudeau a réclamé un
cessez le feu dans le conflit au yémen
et des réponses plus claires sur le
meurtre du journaliste jamal khashoggi
l'emprisonnement du blogueur rice
badaoui et de sa soeur a aussi été
abordé mais sans résultat concret ce
rêve badaoui en soirée il me souligné
qu'il était très conscient de l'enjeu et
qu' il était en train de regarder la
situation mais dans ce sommet de la
discorde le fossé demeure entier et le
communiqué final silencieux sur tous ces
sujets controversés sur le commerce
il n'y a aucune mention de la lutte au
protectionnisme malgré tout ce forum
demeure pertinent croit justin trudeau
le g20 est un endroit justement où les
différents chefs peuvent avoir des
interactions directe et personnelle
comme ça et j'ai été content de pouvoir
avoir ces interactions
c'est un sommet qui remet en question la
mission même du g20 les leaders ont été
incapables de s'entendre sur plusieurs
des enjeux les plus urgents du moment
l'événement qui devait servir à
rapprocher les chefs d'état et de
gouvernement n'ont même pas permis de
limiter les dégâts ici louis blouin
radio-canada ou another